with you here today especially thank you
that's the first time i've ever been
introduced by pharrell williams with the
music so thank you for organizing that
uh my kids will love it um but it's a
it's a genuinely great privilege to
address this incredibly distinguished
audience for the first time in fact
since i became chancellor two and a half
years ago
so
let me take this opportunity
to say thank you
thank you for all your support
your advice your challenge
the country
isn't going to become wealthy and
prosperous solely
because of the things that i do
change doesn't happen behind a desk in
whitehall not even the chancellor's desk
it comes from all of you
when your businesses invest
things get built
when you train someone they
excel when you invent new products and
services that people want to buy
you change the world
that insight
is at the center of my economic outlook
now i know there are sometimes
frustrations and frictions
we won't always completely agree or go
as far as you would like
but you must never
ever doubt
that i
and the government are on your side
you ask for more generous capital
allowances
so we introduced the biggest two-year
business tax cut in modern british
history the super deduction
you ask for more flexibility over
apprenticeships and we're delivering
with lots of improvements including new
flexible training models
you asked us to cut business rates
and we're providing a discount of 50
for shops restaurants gyms any business
in retail hospitality and leisure
of course
there's more to do
but i do want to take this moment to
celebrate the partnership between this
government and all of you
this is very personal for me
so i remember
my very early days
as chancellor
curran described himself as a crisis
president well that certainly i've had
to be the crisis chancellor
but sitting at my desk at the treasury
in those first few days and weeks
reading those daily covert case numbers
by the light of my desk lamp
and i was feeling an almost overwhelming
sense of responsibility
and it was a privilege
and a relief
to be able to call people like carolyn
and rain at the cbi for advice
just
as it is a privilege and a relief now
to be able to call on tony
tony under yours and current's
leadership the cbi
continues to be what it has always been
a vital role and voice in our public
life
so please everyone join me in thanking
them for their extraordinary
contribution and leadership
and rarely has your leadership
been needed more than now
i hardly need to tell this audience that
the economic situation is extremely
serious a perfect storm of global supply
shocks is rolling through our economy
simultaneously
global demand shifting last year from
services to goods and exacerbating
supply chain bottlenecks
russia's invasion of ukraine causing
energy and commodity prices to spike
severely
and now a fresh wave of lockdowns in
china disrupting industrial production
and adding to widespread backlogs in
freight and in shipping now while these
are global forces
they are hitting families and businesses
here at home
just this morning's figures show that in
april cpi inflation was 9
the bank of england now expect inflation
to peak at 10 percent later this year
and those inflationary pressures are
starting to weigh on growth
let me set out
the way through this
let me tell you the plan
a plan to help people with the cost of
living
and
a plan
for growth
so first our plan to help with the cost
of living
it is the bank of england's role to
control inflation
and they are rightly independent
over the quarter century
since we took monetary policy out of the
hands of politicians
inflation has averaged precisely
two percent
and i know the governor and his team are
completely focused on getting inflation
back to target
now our role in government
is to help cut costs for families
i cannot pretend
that this will be easy
as i told the house of commons yesterday
there is no measure that any government
could take no law we could pass
that can make these global forces
disappear overnight
the next few months
will be tough
but where we can act
we will
we are providing
22 billion pounds of direct support
with fuel duty cut by five pencil liter
council tax cut by 150 pounds the warm
homes discount increased to 150 pounds
we're making work pay by increasing the
national living wage and cutting the
universal credit taper rate and in just
a few weeks time
will increase the national insurance
threshold to 12 and a half thousand
pounds
a six billion pound tax cut for 30
million working people
because tackling high inflation is not
just an economic necessity
it is a social
and moral necessity
those who suffer most
are not the wealthiest who can find ways
to protect themselves
it is always the poor
our policy today has focused on
supporting people in work and i make no
apology for that
there is nobility in work it is the best
way out of poverty
and i'm proud that under this government
it always pays to work
for right now
we also have a collective responsibility
to help the most vulnerable in our
society
and so as the situation evolves
our response
will evolve
i have always been clear we stand ready
to do more
at the same time
we need to be careful
as tony rightly warned us this week
at a time of severe supply restrictions
an unconstrained fiscal stimulus
does risk making the problem worse
by pushing up prices still further
embedding high inflation expectations
and creating a vicious cycle of even
higher interest rates and more pain for
tens of millions of mortgage holders and
small businesses
so even as we protect people from the
worst of the crisis
we must continue to be responsible with
the public finances
and get borrowing sustainably under
control and debt falling again
so
our plan will deal with the immediate
impact of inflation cutting costs for
families cutting the deficit
but we are also growing the economy
over the long term higher productivity
is the only way to raise living
standards
so to do that
we will build on our enduring strengths
in the uk our children are some of the
best educated in the world
our incredible universities as we heard
produced the third highest number of
publications worldwide and we have the
second most noble laureates of any
nation
our artists musicians game designers and
filmmakers are creating work that is
defining our era
our economy has decarbonized quicker
than anyone else over the last 20 years
our deep and liquid capital markets
finance the world's commerce
our startups attract more venture
capital than france and germany combined
our language is the international
language of business our agile and
flexible regulation is a model for
others
i could go on and on
but we also do need to be honest
we also need to overcome our
long-standing weaknesses
in investment skills and innovation
even in the decade before the global
financial crisis
capital investment had weakened
research from the resolution foundation
and the lse
shows that lower capital per hour worked
explains around half our productivity
gap with france and germany
on skills
our school and university performance
has improved dramatically
but four in five
of our 2030 workforce are already in
work
so if we want to raise productivity in
this country
we need to do more to support those
already in work
and since the financial crisis
the rate of increase in innovation
has slowed considerably
a weakness that explains almost our
entire productivity gap with the united
states
so why is this happening
the problem i don't believe is any
longer
what the government is doing
public sector net investment
is now reaching its highest sustained
level since the 1970s
yet capital investment by uk businesses
as a percentage of gdp
is a lot lower than the oecd average
government funding for post-16 education
is increasing the prime minister has
announced a lifelong learning
entitlement alongside a plethora of new
skills interventions like skills boot
camps and t levels
but uk employers and businesses
spend just half the european average
training their employees
and over this parliament
we in government are delivering our
pledge
to increase public investment in
research and development by 50
to 22 billion pounds
making us one of the largest investors
in r d
but business investment
in r d as a percentage of gdp
is again less than half the oecd average
so in other words further government
action can only take us so far
we need you the wealth creators the
entrepreneurs the leaders
we need you to invest more train more
and innovate more
and as i've said previously our firm
plan
is to reduce and reform your taxes to
support you to do all three of those
things
that is the path to higher productivity
higher living standards and a more
prosperous and secure future
now in conclusion one of the biggest
debates in economics right now is about
whether the world is facing a great
slowing down
will we ever
again see the kind of transformation
that came
from the introduction of railways to
transport people and goods and ideas
cable and pylons to carry electricity
into factories and homes
machines that freed people from
backbreaking labor
now it's easy to look at the challenges
we face now
and feel disheartened
but i am not
i believe our most exciting companies
are still to be founded our most
talented people are still to be taught
our best ideas are still to be
discovered
our best days lie ahead
government alone cannot get us there
it will take all of us
working together
but we can get there
so let's get to work
thank
you thanks very much
[Applause]
i i i don't get for elle williams it
appears good evening everybody i'm tony
danker the director general and i'm just
stepping in now to do a thank you for
the chancellor the chancellor has to
leave now he has to fly to germany to
see g7 finance ministers as if he